jennifer garner is speaking out against
botox and filler this is a breath of
fresh air yes it is as the actress bugs
hollywood trends to speak out in support
of aging gracefully her candid
confessions come from a new interview
with harper's bazaar with jyn sharing
the beauty wisdom she plans to pass down
to teen daughters violet and seraphina
they're funny and smart and you know i
think they're awesome the 50-year-old
says quote my beauty advice is always
the same look in the mirror less obsess
less and look at the rest of the world
to see what you could be using your time
for instead
she adds we all look at our faces more
than people used to and it doesn't do
you any good quote you obsess over
changes or how to fix something on your
face
jennifer goes on to warn against the use
of botox saying quote be cautious when
it comes to injecting anything into your
face be very very incredibly judicious
and wait as absolutely long as possible
to add anything
don't think you're 37 and you need to be
shooting up your face
she also wants her girls to embrace
their natural beauty
saying there is no need for them to wear
so much makeup or have a constant
blowout you can only hope that your kids
feel great just as themselves just as
they are whatever
whatever form that is you you just want
your kids to feel as beautiful as you
you see them yourselves
well those daughters who she's giving
such liberating advice to are the kiddos
she shares with ex-husband ben affleck
who married jennifer lopez earlier this
month in an intimate ceremony in las
vegas
you look gorgeous
[Music]
somebody's getting married
while j.lo and ben exchanged vows jen
garner was taking her own advice living
her best life away from the mirrors and
enjoying the outdoors she took a getaway
to lake tahoe where she went paragliding
and biking as you can see in this
beautiful makeup free selfie
and speaking of going all natural
jen often goes makeup free on social
media as she lets us in on her recipes
you tell me this isn't a perfect little
meal
[Music]
and workouts
[Music]
when etsy spoke with jen earlier this
year she shared the advice she'd give
her younger self 20 years ago i wouldn't
even talk to her about her career um i
would have a lot to chat with her about
but no i would just tell her to grab
hold of every opportunity and moment and
um and including the times that you get
to go home and be with your friends from
high school and your parents and sisters
and um but you know i don't know i would
just tell her it's gonna be okay just
keep forging ahead
[Music]